I know you guys I've been waiting for
the banishment I'm finally going to do
it and I'm not excited about it it
occurs to me that you don't even know
the punishment is and the truth is I
didn't know what this punishment was
going to be until yesterday but it was
bestowed upon me by the suggestion of
nerdfighters and John Green alike and
now I'm not even going to tell you what
it is I'm just gonna do it I'm just
gonna do it I'm just gonna do it I'm I
got to stop saying I'm gonna do it and
do it I don't want to do it
there's something going on all the time
and it's something that I just can't
define but when we're together online I
wanna know who will I'm so happy that
you're mine I'm a worldwide web girl
world wide web world there is something
I must confess I need a world wide web
boy with the world wide web toy this is
my email address I'm chatting online
with a fantasy guy I'm putting my heart
on the line I'm surfing the net just to
see what I get
it's only a matter of time there's
something going on all the time puffing
bro something that I just can't define
we're together online I want to tell the
world I'm so happy that you're mine I'm
a worldwide web girl in a world wide web
world there is something I must confess
I need a world wide web world blog uh
this is my email address this is my
email on Ivanka
daddy daddy daddy da la da da da do you
wanna have a good time online a good
time on my web girl in a web world
there's must confess throw out a web boy
well I web toy this is my email address
this is my email address this is Ronnie
Catherine totally walked right by law I
was doing this I don't think I'm the
hardest person in the world above with
but I'm not the easiest if you think
it's bad that you have to listen to that
one time first imagine me having to
actually do that and then think about
poor Catherine who had to listen to
every single one of the takes and also
the whole process of figuring out the
chords and learning the song and it's
the day before her birthday oh what a
bad way to spend the day before your
birthday we'll ask if anyone wants to
say happy birthday to Catherine that
they are welcome to do that
in their own special way and if they
would like to do it in video form on
YouTube that would be fantastic you can
send emails to her YouTube channel which
is Elfquest e.l.f KW EST if you want to
send pictures or video and you can put
it on YouTube you can send it sparks fly
up at gmail.com
she loves things that are cute and she
loves a frank and cute with Chris and
Johnny Depp particularly Captain Jack
Sparrow cats shields cats so if you want
to work give me that stuff in you can
their tires John will probably have a
video up this weekend and you guys are
definitely going to enjoy it whenever it
does come out he promised that he's
gonna do two in the next seven days so
that's good he's been dealing with some
stuff and he has been able to make video
and you'll find out what that stuff is
soon hahahaha John I hope I'll see you
this weekend